more support for military mothers
there's a new program offering free
advice from baby feeding experts in the
comfort of your own home
all new parents could always use a
little extra support navigating baby
feeding particularly with military
families the best thing we can do is
improve access to care whether they live
on base or live off base and often
especially because military families are
moving around a lot
it's hard to understand what are the
local resources and networks they have
andrea ipolito served as the director of
the department of veterans affairs
innovators network she designed and
oversaw the creation of a program that
provides tools and resources to improve
the experience of veterans and their
families which led to what she's
currently doing the ceo and founder of
simplyfed it offers breastfeeding bottle
feeding all around support at no cost
for military families this service being
delivered via telehealth helps improve
access to care dramatically for military
families who often feel isolated the
service offers a network of baby feeding
experts starting at 27 weeks of
pregnancy through to postpartum and even
weaning tricare families can receive up
to six lactation consultant appointments
at no cost from the comfort of their own
home they don't have to leave the home
whether it's at 2 a.m 6 a.m 2 p.m in the
afternoon
because we know it's often hard to leave
your home but getting the care and
services that you deserve
so that you can best support yourself
and best support baby in your feeding
and baby feeding journey
this service while freedom military
families also available to non-military
families dependent upon one's health
plan